imagine a place
where your neighbors greet your children
by name
a place with splendid vistas
a place where you can drive just 20
minutes
and put your sailboat on the water it's
a seductive place
isn't it i don't live there
[Laughter]
but i did journey on a 27
000 mile trip for two years
to the fastest growing and widest
counties
in america what is a whitetopia
i define wytopia in three ways
first wytopia has posted at least six
percent
population growth since 2000
secondly the majority of that growth
comes from white migrants
and third a wytopia has an ineffable
charm
a pleasant look and feel a je ne sais
quoi
to learn how and why why topias are
ticking
i immerse myself for several months
apiece
in three of them first st george utah
second coeur d'alene idaho and third
forsyth county georgia
first stop st george a beautiful town of
red rock landscapes
in the 1850s brigham young dispatched
families to st george to grow cotton
because of the hot arid climate and so
they called it utah's dixie
and the name sticks to this day
i approached my time in each wytopia
like an anthropologist
i made detailed spreadsheets of all the
power brokers in the communities
who i needed to meet where i needed to
be
and i threw myself with gusto in these
communities
i went to zoning board meetings i went
to
democratic clubs and republican clubs
i went to poker nights
in st george i rented a home
at the entrada one of the town's premier
gated communities
there were no motel sixes or howard
johnson's for me
i lived in wytopia as a resident and not
like a visitor i rented myself
this home by phone
golf is the perfect seductive
symbol of wytopia when i went on my
journey
i had barely ever held a golf club
by the time i left i was golfing at
least three times a week
golf helps people bond some of the best
interviews i ever scored
during my trip were on the golf courses
one venture capitalist for example
invited me to golf
in his private club that had no minority
members
i also went fishing
because i never fished this fellow had
to teach me
how to cast my line and what bait to use
i also played poker every weekend it was
texas hold'em with a ten dollar buy-in
my poker mates may have been bluffing
about the hands
that they drew but they weren't bluffing
about their social beliefs
some of the most raw salty conversations
i ever had
during my journey were at the poker
table
i'm a gung-ho entertainer
i loved to cook i hosted many dinner
parties and in return
people invited me to their uh dinner
parties
and to their barbecues into their pool
parties into their birthday parties
but it wasn't all fun immigration turned
out to be a big issue
in this whitetopia the saint george's
citizens council on illegal immigration
held regular and active protests against
immigration
and so what i glean from this whitetopia
is what
a hot debate this would become it was a
real time preview
and so it has become
next stop almost heaven a cabin i rented
for myself in coeur d'alene in the
beautiful north idaho panhandle
i rented this place for myself also by
phone
the book a thousand places to see before
you die
liz coeur d'alene is a gorgeous paradise
for huntsman
boatsmen and fishermen
my growing golf skills came in handy in
coeur d'alene i golfed with retired lapd
cops in 1993
around 11 000 families and cops
fled los angeles after the la
racial unrest for north idaho and
they've built an expatriated community
given the conservatism of these cops
there's no surprise that north idaho has
a strong gun
culture in fact it is said north idaho
has
more gun dealers than gas stations
so what's the resident to do to fit in
i hit the gun club when i rented a gun
the gentleman behind the counter was
perfectly pleasant and kind
until i showed him my new york city
driver's license
that's when he got nervous i'm not as
bad as shot as i thought i might have
been
what i learned from north idaho is the
peculiar
brand of paranoia that can permeate a
community
when so many cops and guns are around
in north idaho in my red
pickup truck i kept a notepad and in
that notepad i counted
more confederate flags than black people
in north idaho i found confederate flags
on keychains on cell phone paraphernalia
and on cars about a seven minute drive
from my hayden lake cabin
was the compound of aryan nations the
white supremacist
group
america's promise ministry the religious
arm
of aryan nations happened to have a
three-day retreat
during my visit so i decided to crash it
i'm the only non-aryan journalist i'm
aware of
ever to have done so among
the many memorable episodes of that
retreat
is when abe and aryan siled up next to
me
he slapped my knee and he said hey rich
i just want you to know
one thing we are not white supremacists
we are white separatists we don't think
we're better than you
we just want to be away from you
indeed most
white people in wytopia are neither
white supremacists
or white separatists in fact they're not
there for explicitly racial reasons at
all
rather they emigrate there for
friendliness comfort security safety
reasons that they implicitly associate
to whiteness
in itself next stop was
georgia in georgia i stayed
at an excerpt north of atlanta
in utah i found poker in idaho i found
guns
in georgia i found god the way that i
immersed myself
in this wytopia was to become active
at first redeemer church a mega church
that's so huge
that it has golf carts to escort the
congregants
around its many parking lots on campus
i was active in the youth ministry and
for me personally
i was more comfortable in this wytopia
than say
in a colorado or in idaho or even a
suburban boston
that is because here in georgia
white people and black people are more
historically familiar to one another
i was less exotic in this whitetopia
but what does it all mean wytopian
dreaming whytopia migration
is a push-pull phenomenon full of
alarming pushes
and alluring pulls and why topia
operates
at the level of conscious and
unconscious bias it's possible
for people to be in wytopia not for
racist reasons
though it has racist outcomes
many wytopians feel pushed by illegals
social welfare abuse minorities
density crowded schools many wytopians
feel
pulled by merit
freedom the allure of privatism
privatized
places privatized people privatize
things
and i learned in whitetopia
how a country can have racism without
racists
many of my smug urban liberal friends
couldn't believe
i would go on such a venture the reality
is
that many white americans are affable
and kind
interpersonal race relations how we
treat each other
as human beings is vastly better
than in my parents generation can you
imagine me
going to wytopia 40 years ago
what a journey that would have been
and yet some things haven't changed
america is
as residentially and educationally
segregated
today as it was in 1970
as americans we often find ways to cook
for each other
to dance with each other to host with
each other
but why can't that translate into how we
treat each other
as communities it's a devastating irony
how we have gone forward as individuals
and backwards as communities
one of the wytopian outlooks that really
hit me
was a proverbial saying one black man
is a delightful dinner guest 50 black
men
is a ghetto
one of the big contexts animating
my wytopian journey was the year 2042
by 2042 white people will no longer be
the american majority as such
will there be more whitetopias
in looking at this the danger of why
topia
is that the more segregation we have
the less we can look at and confront
conscious
and unconscious bias
i ventured on my two-year 27 000 mile
journey
to learn where why and how
white people are fleeing but i did
expect to have so much fun on my journey
i didn't expect to learn so much about
myself
i don't expect i'll be living in a
whitetopia
or a blacktopia for that matter i do
plan to continue golfing every chance i
get
and i'll just have to leave the guns and
mega churches
back in wytopia thank you